Kevin Hart famous comedian tapped this
week to host the upcoming Oscars and
then the requisite next step commenced
where people went to dig up his old
tweets and his old comedy bits to try
and destroy him I want to pause here
just for a moment to try to just to
reflect on on this think about how petty
and empty and miserable and wretched you
have to be to to think in that way where
where someone is offered a high profile
job opportunity and your first reaction
is oh let's go through his old tweets to
try to destroy him for no reason at all
that is the thought process of a truly
demented person but apparently there are
many such people in in our country today
so the bullies went to work and they dug
up some old tweets and a couple of lines
from a stand-up special 8 or 10 years
ago and they said the jokes were
anti-gay demanded that he apologized
initially I was impressed because Hart
refused to apologize he said look I've
already apologized I'm not gonna do it
again I'm not gonna keep doing this and
and then he lost the job was was forced
to step down and unfortunately as he
stepped down he apologized again even
though he'd already lost the job but I'm
sure he apologized because at this point
Kevin Hart is a movie star he's making
movies all the time and so he's he's
thinking about that and I guess he
figured that if he doesn't apologize he
might start losing those opportunities
as well
now what were these terribly offensive
anti-gay jokes well the outrage seems to
focus primarily on a bit from his comedy
special back in 2010 where he said that
he's not homophobic but he doesn't want
his son to be gay and then he talked
about the fear that he experiences when
he sees his son playing with with with
you know feminine toys are acting in a
feminine way alright so I think there
are
there are basically two ways of
interpreting a bit like that the first
way is we could say it's a joke he's a
comedian he's telling a joke the whole
point of the joke is that he's saying
he's saying something that's not
considered appropriate in modern society
it's offensive to many people so or to
some people anyway so and that's the
joke that's the whole point of the joke
it's a joke he's telling a joke he's a
comedian telling a joke that's what
comedians do that's one way of looking
at it that that I think is the correct
way of interpreting it the other way to
look at it if you are intent on taking
it seriously and not as a joke well then
okay in that case he is a person a
parent
honestly sharing his own desires and
preferences for his son he's honestly
talking about what he personally wants
for his child and I think even if you
look at it that way it's still
incredibly stupid to be outraged because
it's just his opinion is he not entitled
to his to have his own views about his
about about parenting and his own
priorities and preferences for his
family maybe he really wants his son to
get married and have children so the
family line is carried on it's a really
normal thing for a father to want is he
not allowed to desire that or maybe you
know he's listened to the left claiming
that gays are bullied and persecuted in
our country and he doesn't want that for
his child
whatever his reason that's his opinion
it's his view now what if he had said
what if he had said that he did he
really one of his fears is is that he
doesn't want his son to date a white
woman you know as a black man he doesn't
want his son dating a white woman what
if that was the joke that he had made
again we would be able to look at it in
two ways number one we could say it's
just a joke he's telling a joke he's a
comedian or two we could say he's being
honest he's sharing how he feels what he
wants for his family and I
their way there is no reason to take
offense it would make no sense for me to
be offended as a white person it would
make no sense for me to say how dare you
have your own preferences and priorities
in relation to your own son it's none of
my business if that's what he wants for
his son and whatever but of course I
talk about outrage and I use that word
metaphorically really because there is
rarely any real outrage in this country
outrage is now just perfunctory I mean
did anyone really care about Kevin
Hart's stand-up bit from eight years ago
was anyone really upset about his tweets
I doubt it no no they're just pretending
because this is what people do now you
know I know at first blush it seems like
people are more sensitive now than they
used to be and maybe they are okay they
probably are in a lot of ways but I
don't think that's why the outrage the
the these explosions of outrage I don't
think that's why it's so common I think
it's just a matter of efficiency public
outrage used to be kind of on manual it
used to be stick shift
you had to manually change gears in
order to get the outrage going but now
it's automatic we shift into outrage
mode automatically which we shift into
outrage gear automatically in other
words I don't think there are
necessarily more people offended by
jokes now than there were say 20 years
ago I think it's just that because of
the internet the outrage crew is more
efficient they can cover more ground
they can get outraged quicker and about
more things that's really what that is
that's really what it is with the
internet I think you have basically the
same number of petty busybodies who are
looking to be offended by jokes you the
same number of them but now they have
this because of the technique
in the internet they have this avenue
that allows them to get to it allows
that number one to find a bunch of
things to be outraged about and then it
allows them to very quickly voice that
outrage in a way that's you know doesn't
take a lot of effort you can just send
out a tweet saying outraged by Kevin
Hart and that's it and then boom if
enough people do that you've got an
outraged mob and that is why as I as I
have said a hundred times and I'll say a
hundred more times that's why you should
never apologize to them you should never
apologize to the outraged mob never
apologize no matter what you said no
matter what provoked them whether you
were wrong or right never apologize to
them because it's just a game it's
disingenuous they're not even really
upset and even if they really are upset
you don't owe them anything you didn't
hurt them these are just people out
disconnected from it it how is anyone
really hurt how is your life actually
affected by a joke that Kevin Hart told
eight years ago and then in what way is
anything made better or in what way do
you benefit from him being forced to
apologize
you were never hurt to begin with the
apology does nothing for you so there's
no reason to engage in it and I really
wish the heart hadn't apologized but
more than that I wish we did not have
this crew of of empty board bullies
looking to destroy people for no reason
I wanted to check out there's there's an
email that someone sent I thought was
interesting raises raises a point that
you hear a lot at this time of year so I
wanted to read it and try to respond to
it email says hi Matt I love your
podcast listen to it every day I think
you have really great insight to many
subjects especially religion I guess I
didn't really need to read this part of
the email to you but I am anyway this
holiday season I've been hearing a lot
that Christmas is actually a pagan
holiday
I am a practicing Christian that grew up
in the Catholic Church and in my family
we have always celebrated Christmas as
the birth of our Savior Jesus Christ
I've done some research and I realized
that there are some Christmas traditions
that have a root in the pagan holiday of
celebrating the winter solstice but that
does not change in my heart what
Christmas means to me I am thinking that
maybe Christmas is a mixture of many
different traditions with of course a
heavy dose of commercialism I would love
to hear your take on this and how to
discuss this subject with others that
insist that Christmas is a pagan holiday
that has nothing to do with Jesus thanks
for your consideration all right
yes this is indeed an enduring meme and
you hear it from atheists and Christians
alike mainly from atheist but there are
some Christians who don't celebrate
Christmas because of its alleged pagan
origins and the whole thing is
completely silly in my opinion the first
thing we can say here about whether or
not this or that Christmas tradition has
quote pagan origins the first thing we
can say is it doesn't matter who cares
yes it's probably true that pagans used
Christmas trees in religious rituals
before they were Christmas Christmas
trees so what why does that matter
what does that prove exactly it's not
like we're taking part in the pagan
ritual itself
the Christian Christmas tree supplanted
replaced took over overrode the pagan
tradition by the way pagans also
worshiped in temples does that mean that
we shouldn't go to church pagans had
great big feasts to celebrate their gods
does that mean that we should get rid of
Thanksgiving to pagans were the first to
do a lot of things because the vast
majority of people in ancient times were
pagan before Christianity came along you
had Judaism and then you had pagans you
had you had this small tribe of Jews and
then everybody else in the world was
pagan so as Christianity spread it did
absorb some of the of the culture of
these pagan civilizations but their
culture their
out there religion not their Dogma their
culture so what why does that matter
what's what does that prove and this is
also what makes it really difficult to
say which tradition or which element has
pagan origins because cultures mingle
and interact and change and evolve and
with any one tradition it's often
impossible to say where exactly it
started the the the the Christmas
celebration in modern America is a mix
of many things like the emailer
mentioned there's commercial
commercialization there's there's a lot
of that there's old Christian tradition
as well some of which may have began as
pagan traditions or maybe not and then
hopefully not overshadowed by all of
this you have the actual religious
significance of the event so were pagans
the first ones to use evergreens for
religious purposes probably doesn't
matter worth were the pagans the first
to have a religious feast in late
December yeah doesn't matter
did the whole flying reindeer and fat
guy coming down the chimney thing come
from pagans know those evolved in more
modern times but it doesn't matter
traditions and customs are like this
they change they evolve they take on
different flavors different meanings
over time that's just what it means to
live in a human society and pretty much
any human tradition you can think of has
been influenced and has changed and has
it has origins in many different areas
of the world so what what matters is the
theology of Christmas God incarnate born
of a virgin that's the part that matters
and yeah if you could prove that came
from pagans then we'd have a serious
problem on our hands but you can prove
no such thing because the pagan
theological parallels are way way WAY
overstated by atheists and usually they
are they are overstated by people who
have not the slightest clue about
ancient history or about pagan mythology
so for instance you will hear it
claimed that Jesus is modeled on Mithra
on the pagan god Mithra because among
other things Mithra had a virgin birth
well there are a few problems here
Mithra was born from a rock now perhaps
it was a virgin rock but still I think
we would agree that's a very different
kind of thing
also the cult of Mithra took form kind
of around the same time as Christianity
and and it grew parallel to Christianity
so it seems that Mithra ISM borrowed
from Christianity not the other way
around
another pagan parallel you hear a lot
about is and this isn't a Christmas
thing this is this this is one you hear
around Easter Adonis a pagan deity who
was allegedly a dying and rising God
except there are actually no text saying
that Adonis rose from the dead that's a
misnomer it said that the Egyptian god
Horus this is a big one you'll hear a
lot about you've probably seen that the
Egyptian god Horus had a miraculous
birth like Jesus
yes but the miracle there was that his
mom resurrected his dad gave his dad a
golden penis after his original member
had been cut off and eaten by a fish and
then they conceived Horus it's hard for
me to see much of a theological
connection between that and what
Christians believe you'll hear about the
Greek the Greek God erect theas well
you'll hear that he had a virgin birth
well not really he sprang from the
ground spontaneously when some divine
seed spilled on the ground after a
forted rape attempt in heaven again not
not very similar at all to what
Christians believe and I could go on and
on the point is when somebody mentions
these alleged Jesus pagan parallels all
you have to do is actually read the
stories behind the
the mythical gods they bring up don't
take their word for it go and read it
for yourself and in every case I've ever
seen the parallel breaks down very
quickly on further investigate all you
have to do is just go read for like a
minute and you'll see oh this isn't the
same thing at all
not only that but you also have to ask
when did this pagan myth originated and
what sources do we have for it
notice that the people who make this
argument they they rarely if ever will
give you an actual source for where they
get it they're getting this from a
source says in not you know saying I got
it from this website that's not a source
I mean where is this where did this
information originated from this myth
was written down at some point and what
is the earliest texts we have for for
this myth um and for many of these myths
what you're gonna find is that the
earliest source we have is from like
eight or nine or ten centuries after
Christ meaning again if there was any
influence at all one way or another it
was from Christianity to paganism not
the other way around so the story behind
Christmas is not pagan the traditions
attached originate from many places and
no matter where they came from they're
now Christian so it doesn't matter as I
said though there are there are some
Christians who either don't celebrate
Christmas at all or who don't do the
tree and all that because of the
supposed pagan roots now I had always
thought that that was really a Jehovah's
Witness thing but it seems to be a bit
more widespread than that I don't know
how I don't know how widespread I'm not
really sure how common it is but there
seemed to be a certain sizable number of
Christians who feel this way about
Christmas somebody on Twitter yesterday
I was talking about this and someone
said someone likened the Christmas tree
to the Golden Calf well there's only one
problem here nobody worships
a Christmas tree we don't put the tree
in our home to worship it
we are not tempted to worship it we have
no urge in that direction although look
if it's a stumbling block for you if you
have this intense urge to worship trees
then by all means stay away from this
particular holiday tradition but most of
us have no such urgent we put we put
decorations and it looks nice it smells
nice that's all that's all we do with it
I have I have never in my life ever
heard of a Christian worshipping a tree
or being tempted to worship a tree or
getting anywhere close to worshipping a
tree I have never heard of that it's a
non-issue
by the way pagans worshipped everything
okay
they made God's out of everything they
had hundreds of God thousands really
they had gods for every object every
situation everything in nature every
emotion everything they made idols out
of trees out of rocks out of rivers they
made gods out of animals they made gods
out of the Sun the moon the clouds on
and on and on and on and on so if you if
you I mean pretty much any object you
can think of that existed back then was
probably used in some way in a in a
pagan ritual or it was it was infused
with some sort of of some sort of divine
significance because that's just how
pagans operated so if you have really
set out to to avoid anything that pagans
worshipped you've really really limited
yourself I hope you never sunbathe okay
because worshiping the Sun was a big
thing for pagans I hope you never hope
you never visit a zoo
I hope you don't have any trees or rocks
on your property because all of them are
idols or they were idols to pagans 3000
years ago also a hope
never celebrate your birthday which
apparently this too is a thing among
some Chris I think it's a little bit
less common but arguably birthdays
originated with pagans that was to
celebrate a birthday was was was not was
some that something pagans did has I
mean you're gonna stop celebrating your
birthday maybe you will or maybe you'll
just continue celebrating your birthday
because it doesn't matter what pagans
did what is this thing like if pagans
did it 3000 years ago they've claimed it
for all time and now we can't do it what
an absolutely silly idea and not only
that but it's it's completely
superstitious you have you have I what
you're saying is that a certain object
or tradition carries with it some kind
of curse or something because pagans did
it once but that's not the case remember
st. Paul was asked whether it's okay to
eat meat that was sacrificed to idols
and he said yes go ahead and eat it
because those gods aren't real it
doesn't matter what magic spells were
cast on them it's just meat so eat it
it's just a meal who cares
so whatever way you look at it it's I
what I would say to the person who set
the email is go ahead and celebrate
Christmas and get your Christmas tree
and and and I wouldn't worry about it
alright something else I although listen
if you decide you don't want you don't
want to do a Christmas tree just because
Christmas trees are a huge enormous
hassle and then you've got this this
this hunk of dying wood in your home you
know right next to your baseboard
heaters or whatever if that's why you
decide on to do Christmas tree than I
totally understand all right somewhat
one other thing I wanted to mention
quickly a 10 year old girl got kicked
off the school bus for bullying so her
dad made her walk to school 5 miles and
36 degree temperatures now the only
reason we know about this is that the
dad filmed it drove behind the daughter
filming her and then posted it on social
media and it went viral and and so
that's how everyone knows about it now
as for the punishment itself walking to
school I have no problem with that
arguably five miles and freezing
temperatures is a bit on the extreme
side but we don't know what the girl did
we don't know the full backstory so so I
have no qualms with that disciplining
your child is is good parents should do
that more often however why film it why
do you need to film it and post it on
Facebook a lot of parents do that these
days and I and I just don't get it
I discipline my children all the time
and I have never once even considered
pulling out my phone to get it on video
it's never crossed my mind
like if I have to send my son into
timeout for talking back to his mother
I've never said oh wait a second I got
to get this on video hey guys look hey
guys just live streaming I've got my son
in timeout yep he talked back to his
mother
I just wanted to let you guys all know
that there's never occurred to me to do
that what why why why would why would it
occur to me now I suppose if we're
trying to be very generous
to the parents who do this we could say
that oh well they're just trying to
raise awareness or something but first
of all be very suspicious because
raising awareness is almost always code
for I'm just trying to get attention to
myself it's it's raising awareness is
almost as usually I'm trying to raise
awareness about myself and about my own
virtue and everything because in general
like in general most of the things
we raise awareness about people are
already aware of those things we don't
it's we're all pretty aware of most of
this stuff so if this dad says well I'm
raising awareness about bullying yeah we
know we're aware of bullying we really
are we know that bullying exists we know
it's a problem we're all on the same
page so there is really nothing good
that can come of that there is not one
single person who will see that video
and say oh wow you know what I think
bullying is a problem you know now that
he's rate he has just raised my
awareness of bullying and now yeah okay
I see it now I see I didn't see it but I
see it now no but not a single person on
earth is gonna say that because we are
all completely aware but even if even if
it is about raising awareness of
something for some reason it's still
stupid and harmful to do to your child
but I don't believe that anyway sorry we
are all plenty aware of parents
punishing their kids we're aware of
discipline we're aware of bullying we're
aware of the concept no I think you put
it online because you want people to
congratulate you on your wonderful
parenting skills and in the process you
are publicly humiliating your child you
are using them for self-serving purposes
you are using them for Facebook Likes
and the Internet is forever remember so
when you shame your child online that
will be accessible forever you can never
take it down 30 years from now it will
still be a Google search away so that
your child can be embarrassed about this
forever does that seem fair is that good
parenting now I think a certain amount
of embarrassment can be appropriate in a
punishment I'm not saying that it's
always wrong for us to punish our
children in a way that might embarrass
them there are times when that's
necessary and and making your child walk
to school even if you don't put it
online just making her walk those five
miles she's not gonna be on the bus her
friends will know about it
yeah that's embarrassing you don't need
to put it online
you've already there's already an
element of kind of of a of a very
lies public shaming involved in it which
i think is is there's not anything
necessarily wrong with that but when you
when you take it online and you shame
your child on the internet in front of
the entire world not just her community
not just you know whoever she bullied um
that's that's that that's one thing I
mean those all the people affected by
whatever she did they're all very local
to her there in her school in her
community why does the whole world need
to see that you're you that your
ten-year-old daughter bullied someone
why do millions of humans need to know
about that and then you're also you're
opening your child up to Internet
comments you know you're opening her up
to whatever vile and hateful fit anytime
you put something online like that
especially in a negative way about oh
guess what this person did that's bad
even if it's your own kid you have
opened them up to you've opened them up
to bullying to the to the bullying of
hundreds of strangers who will say vile
and nasty things about them so in order
to teach them a lesson about bullying
you just put them out there to be
bullied by hundreds of strangers many of
whom are probably adults if that's how
you teach them not the bully and then on
top of that you're collecting likes and
you're collecting shares and you're
getting more exposure for yourself for
some reason and that just seems clearly
wrong to be clearly inappropriate not
everything has to be online not
everything has to be a matter for public
consumption it is possible to just deal
with this problem with your family and
your child and do it privately or do it
within the context of your community and
as I said within the context of the
people who were actually affected by
whatever she did
thing good not a single good thing can
come and this is just in general put
putting your kids online nothing good
comes of that in general but to do it in
that context to try to embarrass them I
just think it's it's it's you know it
becomes it's it's not it's not much of a
mystery I guess like where did this
daughter learn to bully well I guess we
just figured out where she learned it
from and I think if if if that's your
thought process as a parent you know
where your your child gets in trouble
for something and then you think oh this
could go viral if I put it online if
that's your thought process that you
that's something that's that's a problem
and I think you you that's disturbing
and that's something you need to seek
counseling about or something I mean
that's something you need to that's
something in your own heart that you
need to really work on but don't work on
it publicly in front of everybody
right all right I guess we'll leave it
there I hope you guys have a great
weekend have a and we'll talk to you
next week Godspeed